i grew up only 30 minutes from hillsdale
college
and we would go and watch sporting
events there
mid to late 80s and hillsdale was a very
good time for the football team
i knew i wanted to play football at the
collegiate level
hillsdale was gracious enough to give me
a scholarship to play
and played all four years there really
football
for me allowed me to come out of my
shell i was
shy quiet not very confident
football gave me confidence and
it totally changed the game for me
[Music]
from a long way back my dad was a very
hard worker
he passed that along to me and then you
know the
football background i think it all kind
of plays together that i wasn't
going to give up so then fast forward to
my time at welch so they make packaging
we're not talking a few you know
they're doing millions a day an
opportunity came up to
be a general manager which was the
ultimate goal run a
branch run a facility 27 years old
come in to a operation of about 45
people one guy literally his nickname
for me and the plant was beaver cleaver
you know i just because i was so young
just a baby that business was losing
money
they needed a spark and so i was going
to provide the spark
first thing i did is i worked alongside
everyone there i learned their jobs i
did the jobs
i remember moving out there and i was
working endless hours a day
chicago has its stress as just being in
chicago you can't get trucks
in and out of places drive an hour and a
half in a traffic jam to get to work
to deal with the stresses of work and
then you go home and you drive another
hour and a half
you get home at eight you don't have
time to have dinner with your family
and so i was missing out i was in the
car or i was at work more than i was at
home
that culminated in a lot of stress
one time in particular where i
the stress it got to me and i almost
blacked out i started to go
out and i caught myself and
i started thinking is it worth
blacking out over
[Music]
we're in walmart we come out we sit down
and i have an emotional breakdown
to my wife we were in the car together
by ourselves without the kids and
i thought he was just going to say
something and we were going to get out
of the car and we were going to continue
on our errand
and then i realized very quickly that he
was struggling i'm bawling and i'm
just so emotional and i said you know i
just feel trapped
i knew that work was stressful but i
didn't realize
where he was emotionally i just feel i
can't
i can't do this you know i i was just
talking to her and
and i and just had to unload that and
she had no idea i'd
held it all inside i just thought oh my
gosh how do we get ourselves in this
situation and none of this is worth it
in my gut it had been stirring for about
a year i wanted to
have my own business something that i
could call
my own something that i could build a
legacy
so i left welch packaging and our plan
was
one year one year to find a business to
buy
the business that i own is a sporting
goods company
blazer athletic equipment we make
equipment
for high schools and colleges
our primary sport is track and field
my customers that i deal with are
dealing with high school
sports high school athletes and
collegiate teams
i get to talk sports with them at trade
shows and
in meetings and couldn't imagine
anything better
i didn't realize when i was there how
important and how great hillsdale was
and football gave me confidence in that
aggressive
arena you know hung up the cleats and
can't i can't play anymore
40 had even if i tried i'd be sore for a
couple weeks or maybe hospitalized
so it switched from a football field to
an office
life is full of hard things there's
always adversity
there's always problems you're going to
encounter that drives me
to be better myself drives me to make
the company better
that competitive nature is what has
given me
the tools professionally
[Music]
there's a set of rules but at the end of
the day you're still
trying to win and i love to wake up and
try to win
you